the taliban now run the prisons and
we're given rare access to the main jail
in herat
the prison governor wants to show us how
well the taliban are running their
justice system
and we're escorted by him and his gunman
the entire visit
the men here have all been deemed
criminals by the taliban
the cells were shown have around 40 men
jammed together
many have been here for months already
and they're accused of stealing adultery
not paying debts and fraud
the prison governor is behind us so they
answer our questions cautiously
but one with a fresh injury tells us
many are employees of the former
government
he says they've been put here without
proof or trials
the governor tells our interpreter not
to translate before we're moved on
we're being told not to ask them any
more questions
and uh
to leave
the taliban promised an amnesty for
those who worked with the foreign troops
or the government they toppled
but our evidence suggests this is not
being applied
instead there are widespread claims that
those now behind bars
are only there because of multiple
vendettas being carried out instead
the governor used to run a secret
taliban prison before they came to power
his office may be different but human
rights groups are worried he's using the
same old techniques he and his men are
implicated in the disappearance of the
female governor of the women's prison
alia razizi disappeared more than four
months ago and she's not been seen since
and the governor admits to us he
personally rang her to come to work
he says he's no idea where she is but
insists she was corrupt and she's
probably claimed asylum elsewhere
alia azizi's family are frantic about
her they knew her prison uniform made
her a taliban target
her career portfolio shows how closely
she worked with the foreign troops once
based in afghanistan and her husband
utterly refutes all the allegations
against her i got a mirror
if she was going to leave she'd have
contacted me by now he says it's all a
lie
he's gone to the capitol to try to find
her the taliban warned him not to talk
publicly about her now he's decided he
has to
[Music]
at first we thought the taliban had
changed he says but they're the same old
taliban doing the same things
god only knows what's going to happen to
our country
there's been a heavy media clamp down
too with unknown numbers of journalists
arrested and tortured hundreds of media
outlets have shut and those remaining
work under strict rules it means
unexplained disappearances are all
suppressed
i think it is
a dark future looking for us
yeah for the media
we are lost our jobs we all lost our
dreams if if at
a talent know that that i a journalist
if we know they know that i had a
political program in the past
they should be killed kill me
the taliban intelligence agency known as
the ishtik bharata is the most feared
group in afghanistan
they control the streets and are
believed responsible for the
disappearances of female activists the
arrests of journalists and any others
identified as taliban critics
all acts which brave afghans point out
they need to stop
i want from them that they should
observe the
international law the human law to
to act and also accept the the word
divorce suggestions to have a
official government in afghanistan
but there's still worrying evidence that
human rights continued to be disregarded
we found children locked up in herat
prison too
what did what did you steal
admob was killed
a bicycle he says a number of others
said they too had been locked up for
weeks for stealing bikes
how are you going on we don't like
it
we don't like nothing here he says and
while children are locked up and those
seen as taliban critics continue to
disappear inside these prisons there'll
be concerns
over those holding the power in this
country
alex crawford sky news afghanistan